With a divine twist and one Hell of an ending,
the final season of Lucifer delivers an incredibly
emotional send-off for all our favourite characters.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the finale to uncover and explain all the
clues and details you might have missed.
Plus we'll discuss whether a season 7 or spin-off
could still be possible.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Although Luci fought a battle to be the new
God, in Season 6 he finds himself full of
doubts about whether he's really the right
angel for the job.
And by the end, he realises his true calling
isn't to rule on high, but to help redeem
the souls of the damned below.
When he said Hell no longer needs a keeper,
it doesn't.
It needs a healer.
After all, who better to help those condemned
to Hell than Lucifer who'd lived there for
millennia in his own Hell Loop of sorts believing
it was his job to punish people?
It wasn't until he went to LA and began therapy
with Dr Linda that he was able to slowly deal
with his anger and self-loathing.
It took him years to fully understand himself,
and during that time he almost transformed
entirely into a monstrous devil form at the
end of Season 4.
His devil face, which we've seen since the
show began, was a crucial part of Luci's sense
of guilt and self-hatred, as God explained
to his son.
Why did you choose that face?
Deep down, that face is how you see yourself.
So, when Lucifer sees his daughter Rory giving
in to her anger and manifesting her own devil
face against LeMec, he recognises it for what
it is and begs her not to give in to those
urges.
Killing him won't change what he's done, but
it will change you.
I know what it's like to be consumed by guilt,
by anger and self-hatred.
As Rory later explains, Lucifer has a special
gift that troubled people like her can relate
to.
When I looked in your eyes, I knew you understood
my anger and the guilt more than anyone else
could.
And when Luci, Chloe and Rory realise that
it was his advice to Dan's ghost that helped
him finally ascend to Heaven,
Chloe explains that helping those who are
stuck within their own guilt-ridden Hell Loops
could be Lucifer's true purpose.
You can help everyone.
Every Dan down in Hell who deserves another
chance.
Luci agrees and thinks he'll be able do the
job part-time,
which does make some sense when you consider
that time in Hell moves differently so he
could be down there delivering hundreds or
thousands of years of therapy and only be
gone in Earth time for a few months.
However, Rory explains that wouldn't be possible
because if Lucifer is there for her as a father
as she grows up,
she'll never become angry enough to time travel
to the past and help him arrive at this moment
of self-discovery about his ability to help
rescue millions of condemned souls in Hell.
Everything that we've been through, it all
leads to what Dad just realized, that he needs
to help those lost souls.
We can't change anything, or he might never
get that idea.
What Rory's describing is a type of time paradox
which you can pick apart if you start to think
about it too much, so I suggest for pure enjoyment
of the show to just go along with it.
My advice?
Don't overthink it.
In fact, this Season 6 storyline with Chloe
and Lucifer's daughter Rory being crucial
to his ultimate destiny
fits nicely as one of the reasons he was so
insistent on bringing Chloe back from Heaven
at the end of Season 5.
It's not your time.
You need to come back.
There were also some theories at the end of
Season 5 that Chloe getting stabbed in the
stomach with a staff made from the Tree of
Life would lead to her pregnancy,
and given that, I like how Rory is framed
in this shot with the Tree of Knowledge in
the stained glass window to her side.
Lucifer and Chloe's final moments together
on Earth as they ready themselves for him
to go to Hell
will no doubt have been heart-breaking for
Deckerstar fans and even more so because this
scene mirrors the first time they met in the
Pilot.
"Lucifer Morningstar"?
Is that, uh, a stage name or something?
God-given, I'm afraid.
So, um, Lucifer Morningstar...
Is that, like, a stage name or something?
God-given, I'm afraid.
And when they play Heart and Soul together,
it's a tender call-back to the first time
they duetted with that song in Season 1.
I think you're gonna miss my incredible musical
prowess the most.
Luci also played "Heart and Soul" in the third
season episode "Quintessential Deckerstar"
as a way to remind Chloe of their time together
before Pierce came along.
And the Albanian field wench mention is also
a cute shout-out to the first season when
Chloe woke up in Lucifer's bed after getting
drunk the night before.
You snore, by the way.
Like an Albanian field wench!
Fortunately though, the sweet part of the
bittersweet ending promised by the showrunners
is still to come when decades later after
Chloe dies,
she goes to the afterlife and Amenadiel takes
her to Hell to reunite with Lucifer, proving
they really are partners to the end.
Hello, Detective.
I thought you could use a partner.
Lucifans will surely love that they got to
hear Lucifer call Chloe "detective" one final
time, which neatly parallels the start of
the season when Luci called her by her name
and she replied:
'still not used to you calling me that.'
That very last time he calls her "detective"
is also a nice way of acknowledging that although
Chloe gave up her police job at the end of
Season 5 so she could help Luci in his godly
duties,
being a detective was still very much part
of her DNA.
And we saw that in the first episode of Season
6 when Chloe just couldn't stop herself investigating
the magician murder scene.
Once the detective, always the detective.
And remember this Deckerstar reunion in Hell
will be especially sweet for Lucifer given
that while decades have passed on earth between
Luci leaving and Chloe's death,
it's probably been hundreds of thousands if
not a few million years in Hell time for Lucifer.
I love the fact that Lucifer's therapy room
in Hell appears to be a replica of Dr Linda's
office, proving just how great her influence
on him has been.
And it's especially interesting that after
Luci counselled the good doctor in Season
5 on how she could reconcile with her daughter,
she told him this.
Awfully insightful of you, Lucifer.
Maybe you should become a therapist.
On Lucifer's couch in Hell is Reese, Linda's
ex-husband whose Hell Loop made up the Season
3 episode "Off The Record".
Even now, Reese still can't break out of his
loop, but Lucifer is there diligently advising
him to confront his guilt head on rather than
avoiding it.
And when Reese says he feels he's a lost cause,
Lucifer's reply sums up the show's key premise.
Because if the devil can be redeemed, then
anyone can.
Now, let's get into that final montage revealing
how everyone else ended up at the close of
the series.
It begins in the Silver City with Amenadiel
taking his place as Amenagod, which many Lucifans
suspected would happen given his desire to
help people and how well suited he seems for
the position.
After all, remember the advice about humanity
he gave Luci back in Season 4:
Humans, Chloe, people are amazing.
I'm only now just realizing how lucky we are...
that we actually get a chance to connect with
them.
And then there were his wonderful words to
Ella in Season 5 about her feelings that she
didn't fully deserve God's love.
You see, I think if God was standing right
here, right now, in front of you, that he
would tell you to take some of that faith
that you have in him...
and put it in yourself.
And as it turns out Amenadiel's words foreshadowed
his rise to God status.
Similar to his brother, Amenadiel also wants
to reform his part of the cosmos and make
Heaven a better place.
I think every single angel should spend time
here..
walking among humans, just like I did...
to get to really understand humanity.
He also agreed with Lucifer to take joint
ownership of Lux and in the montage we see
him gather his team of angels who he'll send
to work at Luci's club so they can mix with
all types of humans.
And rather than operating in the mysterious
ways of their Father who left his family to
work things out by themselves, Amenagod plans
to involve his angelic siblings in God's work
and keep them informed.
Being God...
...is what I truly desire.
With Amenadiel now firmly in charge of Heaven,
the closing montage shows Ella caressing her
cross, her faith renewed as she senses the
big guy has returned.
In some ways, Ella underwent perhaps the most
dramatic arc of all in the final season, as
she finally discovered the truth about her
celestial friends,
something teased all the way back in the "God
Johnson" episode of Season 2.
Is it really so crazy?
I mean, what if God was one of us?
Many Lucifans were hoping Ella would find
out the truth, especially as in Season 5 she
actually met God himself who helped her through
the darkness she was feeling at the time.
The darker the darkness, the brighter the
light.
And you, Miss Lopez, shine so very, very brightly.
I can see it all the way from Heaven.
Ella must have had a few suspicions before
then,
but God talking about seeing her from Heaven
and then disappearing mysteriously seems to
have been the trigger for her secret investigation
and conspiracy board in Season 6.
And by the time of Maze and Eve's wedding,
Ella's suspicions are all but confirmed as
she sees Amenadiel talking to an invisible
Dan, and Carol comments about the strange
smell at the ceremony.
What did you think?
What, we were at some, like, hell monster
wedding, attended by decaying zombies?
Ha ha!
Hah!
At the afterparty, Ella can't take it anymore
and blurts out that she knows the truth.
I know that Lucifer is the actual Devil!
Not, like, the most Method actor ever.
That's a reference to what she said to Lucifer
when they first met in Season 2 and he told
her his name.
Are you...
The Devil?
A method actor?
What?
Ugh.
When Chloe confirms the truth to Ella, she's
not shocked because she already believed in
celestial beings, but she is angry with everyone
for excluding her from the club.
But by the time Luci says farewell in the
next episode, Ella's now at peace, thanks
to her chat with Carol, and understands why
they never told her.
You don't have to know everything to have
trust.
Not when you know each other's hearts.
And given how many "happy" geeky T-shirts
we've seen Ella wear throughout the series,
I can't think of a better way to signal that
the young women's STEM foundation that Luci
established for her is up and running than
by showing her hand out those T-shirts.
The montage next shows Chloe returning to
the LAPD, part of the plan that she discussed
with Amenadiel to be God's point person in
the police department.
Notice there's a time skip next, so when we
come back to Chloe we can see she's been promoted
and that she's taken the opportunity to promote
Officer Harris to detective.
Hopefully, given the show's theme of growth,
Chloe is using the powers at her disposal
now to change the system along with colleagues
like Harris.
Amenadiel even pops by to check in on things,
something that Harris seems to sense, as after
all they had worked together.
The montage also checks in on Dan who, as
so many of us expected, made it to Heaven
to be with his true love Charlotte Richards.
And, of course, he gets to eat Pudding Plus,
which as we know from Season 3 is what Dan
prefers:
Pudding Plus is my favorite, okay?
Twice as much protein as all the other brands.
Some more fun details in this scene are the
"40 Whole Years of Being Dan" mug referencing
the time he was alive on Earth;
and the fact that Charlotte is getting waffles
for her heavenly treat is a call-back to the
waffle-maker that Dan bought her in Season
3 shortly before she was killed.
In Season 6, we learn that the lingering guilt
holding Dan back from Heaven was his belief
that he wasn't a good enough role model to
his daughter Trixie.
When he goes to visit her in LeMec's body,
he confesses these feelings;
however, Trixie replies that he was the best
Dad ever.
But he made so many mistakes.
Everyone makes mistakes.
And my dad taught me that mistakes are important.
And we need them so that we can learn and...
do better next time.
This is again the big theme of the whole series:
that there is always a path for anyone to
redemption.
And as Trixie tells Dan that she's proud of
her Dad, the guilt he feels washes away and
a light calls him up to Heaven.
As the montage continues we get to see Charlie
celebrating his second birthday and, as predicted,
a set of wings pop out proving he has celestial
traits after all.
Amenadiel gives a little punch in the air
as he's clearly delighted, as many Lucifans
will also be.
Charlie being an angel also resolves the plot
point from Season 4 about why Remiel sensed
the birth of a new celestial on Earth.
As to why Charlie's wings didn't show up until
now, it's likely because as a new-born he
was too young to self-actualise.
If that's the case, it seems Linda's attempts
to raise "the best child possible"
by giving baby Charlie access to an incredible
range of classes from Japanese to art appreciation
has paid off, helping him to develop and self-actualise
at a very young age.
The montage also catches us up with everyone's
favourite demon, Maze, who turned down the
opportunity to rule Hell together with Eve,
a theory I mentioned back in Season 4.
Instead, thanks to Linda's dinner table therapy,
Maze explains that rather than torturing souls
in Hell, what she really wants to do is to
carry on as a bounty hunter on Earth.
It's so much better when they're still alive,
you know.
You can really feel the fear.
During that dinner table session, Maze tells
Eve she's her true Hell, and so by the end
we see they've found their bliss hunting down
and punishing perps,
something Eve also enjoys as we saw how she
relished doing that with Luci in Season 4.
Maze's farewell with Luci was exceptionally
emotional and when she gives him her demon
blade, it's especially significant because
her knives have been an integral part of her
since we first met her in Season 1.
No matter what, you will always have a piece
of me.
In fact, that demon blade is likely her last
one, as the other one was melted down at the
end of Season 5 to create the demon blade
bullets Chloe used in the celestial battle
at the Olympic stadium.
The montage concludes with a phone call and
news that baby Rory has been born.
And Maze's excitement at the knife gift she's
brought for the newly born babe reminds me
of the scene where she was showing Trixie
an assortment of weapons in Season 4 and slipped
her a blade on the way out.
Maze, you know she's not allowed to play with
knives.
Relax, Dan, these knives aren't for Trixie.
They're for a baby.
I thought the way the series wrapped up was
really well done and although it's been confirmed
this really is the final season,
it's nice to imagine that Lucifer and Chloe's
story could continue in some form down in
Hell.
They already both worked a case down there
in Season 6 when they investigated Jimmy Barnes's
Hell Loop.
It's unlikely we'll be getting a Season 7
anytime soon, but other popular shows have
been revived years later, and with the number
of resurrections this series has had already,
anything's possible!
Would you like to see a Season 7 or a spin-off
show and if so what would you like to see
in it?
So, what did you think of the final season
of Lucifer?
Comment with your thoughts and theories below.
And if you enjoyed this video, a like and
a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left to watch my next Lucifer video or
tap right for something else you're sure to
like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!